hey Tony
[Music]
him them indeed democracy
wins and MAA
loses and their problem this morning is
they're like yeah the reason why we lost
is because we're not we're not Nazi
enough that's that's probably the
problem that that's probably the reason
why so many people came out and voted
against us is because we're just not
Nazi
enough oh my God these Bon heads
keep
going keep
going please do not put down the shovel
can we get you a magabo is it is it
appropriate if we get them a Hitler d8
here to absolutely bury their political
party now I do want to say and I I was
in a a room this morning with some
people on Discord and I was telling them
this morning someone brought up the
point about Mike Johnson being the
Speaker of the House the wiener of the
house the election denying wiener of the
house um here's the thing about this
[Music]
guy M Johson that's the one that's the
one that's the guy small wiener energy
micro Johnson I am super excited that
this is their
guy how beautiful is it that
Mike Johnson is the walking epitomy of
what the country went and voted against
yesterday like his entire worldview
people in red States like Virginia red
States like Ohio red States like
Kentucky went and said
off with your stupid worldview that
women don't have rights to healthcare
you can kiss my ass and you know
what's
great is Bannon Steve Bannon you know on
his Trader TV News Network this morning
this
morning they're they're blaming it on a
woman that's right this morning a bunch
of old ass wrinkly ball sacks taking
away women's right to health care and
women's right to privacy in a doctor's
office right they they turn they
overturned roie Wade and they're
doubling down in these states trying to
make sure that women can't have the
right to health
care and they're like you know what you
know why we lost because of a woman
because of a woman we need to get rid of
that woman at the RNC like they have no
clue they have no clue why people went
and voted against
them they have not a clue I told you
this yesterday that that Americans vote
against stuff and I talked about
affiliation yesterday remember this
this is one reason why I thought I
thought Basher would lose in Kentucky I
was wrong I was wrong I would admit it
when I'm wrong I really thought Basher
would lose by one two% and really
honestly I thought it was going to be
such a narrow a narrow loss that there
would be automatic
recounts but he won by like three or
four points I
think which is six points from my
optimism my optimism was I don't know if
I displayed yesterday well enough but I
was not down and out I was not all sad
about what would the outcome was going
to be for this morning